Throughout its entire history,
mankind has witnessed many wars and border changes,
the birth of empires and the rise of dictatorships.
But a “genocide” has always been the most dreadful.
It means the deliberate rejection of humanity,
the purpose of destruction of people
for their beliefs, ethnicity, nationality, or race
and, in fact, the annihilation of people for who they are.
The Holodomor became one of the biggest crimes
against humanity in world history.
As a result of Soviet policy in Ukraine in 1932–1933,
millions of people were killed.
Ukrainians were starved to death
for their nationality, language, identity,
and their denial to follow
that communist totalitarian machine
which forcibly led everyone to their fake
“bright future of communism” through blood and torture.
On 30 December 1922, a new state was born
that united hundreds of nations and cultures
by means of military interventions and revolution —
the Union of Soviet Socialist Republics (USSR).
Another name for this “union”
was “the prison of the nations”.
Communism became a new policy,
the new ideology, religion, and culture
of this new state, its past and present.
And in the meantime,
it became an excuse to kill millions of people.
As a part of its economic policy,
the newly formed state set a course for collectivisation.
Presented as creating “heaven on earth”,
in reality it turned into a forced organisation
of private individual farmers
into collective farms owned by the state.
In a utopian world, this was meant to become
a voluntary surrender of people’s own land and cattle;
people were supposed to pass
all that property on to the state,
to work collectively every day,
and then to distribute the produce among everyone who was working —
according to the level of their contribution.
The slogan was: “The one who does not work does not eat.”
But the real motivation of the Soviet regime
was to rob and destroy Ukrainian villages.
For farmers, their land and its cultivation
were the foundation of their well-being;
their families’ prosperity depended on that.
To surrender their land was to surrender the confidence
in their own future and their identity.
This meant giving away everything they earned
through their hard work over several decades —
giving it away to the state,
whose values and ideology were completely alien.
And as a reward people would be allowed to exchange
their recorded “working days” for miserable food rations
at the end of each year.
Every ethnic group has its own specifics.
Ukrainians  are proprietors.
They are proprietors.
You see, when we say...
when we use Stalin’s term “kurkul”(Ukr. for “kulak”)...
If you look up the word “kurkul”
you’ll see that it means a “kite” (bird of prey).
A bird that pounces on and swoops onto its prey.
So they decided to use this metaphor of “kurkul”
as something predatory, sneaky;
something that snatches and steals, and so on.
But those whom they called “kurkuls”
were usual farm owners.
Nearly 9 out of 10 Ukrainians lived in villages in those days.
Most of them owned farms.
They were not very enthusiastic about no longer
being independent farm owners but turning into “slaves”
who would be working for food instead.
So in the early 1930s there were over 4,000 protests
of Ukrainian farmers against such an initiative from the state.
They refused to work for some abstract ideological constructs
while their children had nothing to eat.
So their individualism and sense of national identity
became for the Soviet Union a stumbling block
at the gates to its collective heaven.
That’s why by 1932 an unrealistic grain
procurement plan
was set for Ukraine,
imposing a quota of 356 million poods of grain.
One pood is roughly 16.38 kg.
This is an equivalent of about 5.8 million metric tonnes.
So you can imagine how unrealistic such an amount was.
To officially approve this plan,
Stalin’s closest associates — Kaganovich and Molotov — arrived in Kharkiv.
They were both clearly aware of Stalin’s intention
to destroy any existing opposition at all costs, especially in Ukraine.
The Holodomor was civilizational annihilation of Ukrainians.
The objectives of Adolf Hitler and Joseph Stalin were different.
Adolf Hitler’s objective — one of his major political goals —
was to fully destroy the Jewish people.
Because this was a part of Nazism racial ideology.
Joseph Stalin aimed to destroy
such a civilizational phenomenon as Ukrainians.
To prevent the Ukrainian people from playing
their independent role in history
and in civilisation ever again.
That was because Russian chauvinists,
whom Stalin, despite being a Bolshevik, belonged to,
were absolutely gutted with what was taking place
in Ukrainian land in 1917–1920.
And even after that — when even under the Soviet occupation,
the party and economic elites continued conversations about independence.
And at the same time,
the protests and resistance of the farmers continued.
And it became clear to Stalin, who was a great expert in this,
if you destroy Ukrainian villages, physically wipe them out,
you make it impossible for Ukrainian nation to develop.
After the first waves of collectivisation,
farmers began to oppose it en masse —
they were leaving collective farms (“kolhosps”),
taking back their inventory, cattle, and grain.
On 7 August 1932 the resolution
“On Safekeeping the Property
of State Enterprises, Collective Farms
and Cooperatives, and Strengthening Public
(Socialist) Property” was enacted.
This document was better known
as “the Law of Five Ears of Grain”.
For the theft of any collective farm property,
the offenders could be executed by shooting;
should they have any “extenuating circumstances”,
they could “get away” with imprisonment for at least 10 years.
According to “the Law of Five Ears of Grain”,
people were not allowed to collect even crop residues.
During that time special patrol brigades went from house to house
in a village to confiscate all grain people had.
Molotov’s enthusiasm had no limits: by 18 November 1932
he introduced blacklists, or so-called “black boards”.
If a village entered such a list, it would become surrounded
by the army units, blocking entry into or exit from the village,
taking away all essential goods from shops,
such as salt, matches, paraffin, and confiscating any food.
In other words, it was a siege,
in which people would slowly starve to death.
The only territories where such a regime was introduced
were Ukraine and Kuban,
the territories mostly populated by Ukrainians.
The Resolution of the Central Committee
of the All-Union Communist Party (Bolsheviks)
and the Council of People’s Commissars of the USSR,
signed by Stalin and Molotov,
isolated Ukrainians by preventing them from leaving
the Ukrainian SSR and Kuban to get any grain.
During the spring and the early summer of 1933,
the highest rates of mortality were observed among the local population.
Nothing like this was done
to any other administrative region or Soviet Republic.
In the sinister resolution,
which was signed by Stalin and Molotov on 14 December 1932,
titled “On Grain Procurement in Ukraine, North Caucasus and Western Region”,
which was the region of Smolensk those days...
It did not mention any reason
why the Smolensk region could not meet the procurement plan.
Or what punishment the Smolensk region deserved
for not performing according to the plan.
But the main reasons mentioned in that document
were the so-called “perpetrators” who allegedly infiltrated
managerial positions at collective farms
and warehouses, and so on.
Not only in Ukraine but also in Kuban.
So the Smolensk region did not have
any penalties or punishment.
But for the regions of Ukraine and the North Caucasus,
which Kuban was, the document was very prescriptive.
First it demanded to have public trials of a few secretaries
and heads of the party local committee in Ukraine,
and sentence them to 5–10 years of imprisonment.
And also, what’s important, to stop the Ukrainisation program.
To cover the mass mortality,
Stalin deliberately manipulated the statistics.
The world was presented with data
demonstrating high birth rates in the USSR in the early 1930s,
whereas any facts about the catastrophic reduction
of the population in the Ukrainian SSR were concealed.
Those who survived kept quiet for many decades.
Otherwise they would risk their own safety
and the safety of their families and friends.
The Soviet rule triumphed —
the resistance of the population was broken down
by destroying anyone who had stood against.
Any survivors were intimidated,
and they remembered well what could happen to those who opposed.
They learned that no weapon was needed to kill —
the famine alone was enough.
Many more years had passed before one of the biggest crimes
against humanity became revealed to the world.
By 2020 17 countries recognised
the Holodomor as a form of genocide.
Ukraine was among them,
who had already done so in 2006.
For Ukraine that meant deep rethinking of the country’s past,
evaluation of the tragedy’s impact on the country’s present,
and definition of the course for future development.
The Holodomor taught humanity the high price
for silent inaction in the face of a global crime.